well joining us this week on made in
Germany to talk about shopping mania and
more around the holiday season is Kim
Bischoff a consumer psychologist who
knows all about what's going on in our
heads when we start to reach for our
wallets I'd like to know exactly what
does go on in my head what what are the
tricks that retailers use and and how do
we actually get tricked in the first
place okay so what we all know is that
you don't you don't address that it's
five euros but you say it's four years
ninety nine which is almost five euros
but we are reading from left to the
right so we see four and not five which
actually makes us buy it much easier we
all know that why why do we fall for a
time and again you know I find myself
saying I was only four euros actually
five yeah and we fall for it because as
I said like it's a lower number so even
though we know it like we were attached
to it somehow but we don't fall for all
the tricks all the time and that's
that's the good thing about buying so
when we use it much more often then we
learn about it and we make experience
with it and then we're much less willing
to pay for for example very expensive
product very expensive lipstick where
you know okay the quality is not so good
so there is learning in it so we're not
just like falling for all the tricks all
the time okay the first time it gets
even simpler than the $4.99 I mean they
can say it it was 100 euros it's now 50
euros it's another trick that we fall
for time and again but what I'm getting
at are we all programmed to feel
fantastic about getting a bargain is
that the buzz that we're looking for of
course it's always about emotions as
well okay so if we agree on something
then we feel well and both parts feel
well so maybe the person you're talking
to someone who wants to sell you the
lipstick and you're saying okay so now I
get it for 20% less then I'm happy the
other person is happy which is an
emotional aspect and that is why of
course it has it has a positive outcome
in this case and in other countries of
course this is all part of
of the Boeing buying experience
bartering for example in places like
Thailand it's something that's actually
fun enjoyable and is expected as well
whereas in Western countries it's the
rules are a little different but I think
the process seems to be the same
wouldn't you agree yeah well it has to
do with somehow topics the process is
the same so we bargain somehow in an
aspect of it you would say okay can I
get this maybe 20% less you don't go
into the shop and ask here in Germany
but you wait for the day where you know
it's gonna be 20% less and when it comes
to actually not buying for yourself but
buying for others when it comes to
Christmas say the buzz there is is just
the same isn't it yeah so buying four of
us also has this aspect of really
building relationships ok so what you
want to do is you want to show intimacy
as well you want to show look we're
close to each other that is why that is
why I know what you would like ok there
is actually more at stake than just
getting a bug definitely yeah and what
if that's not reciprocated I mean
sometimes I've got presents from people
who I've thought the parents of a friend
who wasn't really a friend and I thought
hmm what's that all about and they said
they give you a present you don't have
one and and I wasn't really expecting
anything at all ok yeah then of course
this create service creates a difference
and you wanna this creates tension
somehow and you want to reduce that
tension so you really don't feel well
but the other person feels very well in
this case because he was somehow a bit
more dominant on giving you the present
the humane aspect of all of this Germans
seem to rate low in comparison to other
countries is that right that's true
there are a lot of studies who show that
in Germany we have less humane
orientation which means that the society
rewards individuals for being generous
for example so but interestingly in
German in Germany is that we wish to be
much higher we really want to have that
so it means that we want the society to
reward and encourage people to be
generous
and with with the holiday season I mean
that's that's a season where people buy
presents that's the season where people
want to be kind to each other
and generous to each other so there is a
fit and that is why fit to your wish you
know the environment says okay
be generous and Germans say ok yes we
want to be more generous so that's of
course where it brings you into action
and also brings you into buying presents
in France the 470 euros yeah they I
would be careful because some pay very
little a less pay a lot so the average
of course is somehow there but yeah you
can see that they want to be generous in
Bishop thank you very much for coming
today thank you very much